for more information on tutoring or how
to support moofy university and the
production of more videos please visit
moof university com thank you and enjoy
next is electron capture so we've
already seen how an electron can be
represented we saw it as a beta minus
particle because a beta minus particle
is an electron however here I'm not
going to represent it that way because
it's a little bit different what's going
on okay so here we're going to put it
we're going to i'm just going to use the
the e- notation okay so this one this
first one no no beta particle
representation here so as electron
capture and so this side even though
we've seen this thing before now it's
going to be on the left side of the
nuclear equation it's the only one that
we're going to talk about where the
particle other than the nucleus is on
the left side so let's get to the
example we have chromium 51 here so we
have an a of 51 and z of 24 so our n is
equal to 50 1-24 which is 27 and over
here we've got this electron so what's
going to happen is that this chromium
nucleus is going to capture an electron
I'll get into where this is coming from
in a second because some people might be
freaking out already and then it's going
to get the daughter so what's gonna
happen to the daughter well 51 plus zero
is 51 for the a value Z 24-1 is 23 so
the right side has to equal 23 the lex
left side equal 23 so that is going to
be vanadium vanadium 51 it does a
daughter ok so what's going on with this
electron thought we were talking about
the nuclear reactions right nuclei the
nucleons right
where's this electron coming from there
are no electrons in the nucleus well so
that's what I got written over here so
from where I thought we were in a new
piss where it comes from it comes from a
low energy orbital ok so again we
haven't talked about orbitals yet and
they're not incredibly important right
now at this very moment but the idea is
that an atom will have electrons sort of
surrounding it some are closer than
others the ones that are closer to the
nucleus with low energy there are
certain locations where there are closer
to the nucleus their lower in energy and
further away they're high on energy but
the idea is that electrons and
low-energy orbitals are close to the
nucleus so what happens is that the
nucleus can capture it grab it and give
a Morse and using this decay process to
give a more stable daughter nucleus ok I
didn't put the end here the end here is
50 1 minus 23 which is 28 ok so what
happened here as far as the AZN n well
the a didn't change it went for 51 251
so it's the same what happened is the z
VZ went from 24 to 23 so it decreased by
1 decrease by 1 and the N when from 27
to 28 so it increased by one so notice
that these results the result here in
fact all three of these results this is
the same results as what we just talked
about in the previous video the same
results as positron emission right just
a different way to do it the general
form can be shown here like this
electron on the left side so that's what
we got here so there are two ways to
make this happen two ways to get these
these results of these effects so we saw
that positron emission occurred because
there were too few neutrons and
electron capture occurs for the same
reason when there are too few neutrons
in the nucleus so however this is a
little bit different now it combines a
proton with that low energy that
electron from low energy orbital to make
a neutron you got a proton plus an
electron to give a neutron so proton has
the 11 notation electrons 0 negative 1
VA and Z and then the neutron 1 is 0 if
we add up the A's on both sides we've
got the AIDS on the Left we get 1 plus 0
is 1 on the right side it's also one and
then the Z is 1 minus 1 equals 0 which
equals the zero over here on the right
side so electron capture occurs when
there are too few neutrons so one of the
protons combines with an electron to
give a neutron so we have one less
proton and one more neutron so that's
electron capture how that video is
helpful thank you for watching if you
found that video helpful don't forget to
Like comment subscribe and share with
friends thank you and happy studying